wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you do
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the surprising
power of small habits
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one rest and recover with robin sharma
in the 5am club there's a model that i
think is
profound because you're right we live in
a world that evangelizes non-stop hustle
it's all about the hustle if if you're
not scheduled 24 7 then you're a loser
and you're not doing something right
what i believe and the research actually
bears this out the elite performers
don't operate as marathoners it's more
like a sprint the energy project for
example has done some wonderful work in
this field
and so i have
the model is basically hec your high
excellence cycle and your deep recovery
cycle in other words there are periods
through the day where you bring on
intense fire intense creativity and then
you pull back and recover so one of the
rituals in the book is that the 6010
method you work for 60 minutes it's full
on fire sprint 10 minutes you recover
you drink a cup of tea you meditate you
listen to music then you come back with
an alarm clock in front of you another
60 minutes of profound work creative
work sweaty work and then another 10
minutes of recovery and then you do that
during the week you take two days off or
three days off to refuel and then as you
probably do as well you take you know a
month off or two weeks off and so what
i'm trying to suggest um
is
if you're if all you're doing
is being an elite performer
then you're going to actually deplete
the very assets that allow you to own
your game and play the long game in the
book there's five assets of genius it's
not just you know your talent i believe
it's your mental focus your physical
energy your personal willpower your
original talent and your daily time and
so smart creative people and the most
productive people they work really hard
and then they rest without guilt and
they recover and they have fun i mean
the japanese novelist haruki murukami
says when i'm not writing and enjoying
life my ideas are incubating and i'm
writing my next book habit number two
set triggers with brendan burchard i
think
the challenge
you have when you're good
is that you're good yeah so like i'm
doing pretty good already yeah it's easy
the the better you get the more
expertise development you get the easier
it is to show up and go through the
motions yeah you don't have to prepare
as much you don't have to practice as
much you just get results whatever you
can do is good enough yeah but what
happens with it eats at them
because they know they got more in the
tank
and they're like you know what that was
good but i could have gotten another and
it's not that they're dissatisfied we
take on that myth in this book high
performers are not dissatisfied so
people who say never be satisfied
they got to look at why they're saying
that because
it's not true because high performers
are satisfied they're they're striving
satisfied doesn't mean they're not
striving for the next big thing want to
become better but they're happy
hyperwares are happier than all of their
peers i mean by significant almost
double digits so it's really significant
um but i think for me
i need to constantly be reminding myself
like okay
what is the reason you need to perform
really well right now
and i need to be more consistent about
that question
um so i set up triggers in my life to do
that you know um
from every time i stand in line
i have a line trigger i have door
triggers i have phone triggers
you know so when i stand in line i
always say what level am i right now
in terms of my presence and energy
scale 110. one i suck i'm dead i'm not
even alive not even feeling grateful you
know ten i'm like i'm vibrant i'm joyous
here i am um and i i rate myself
consistently on that and it just
retouches me like the knee i i want to
feel it's necessary to be grateful
i want to feel it's necessary to be
great i want to feel it's necessary to
do my best but you don't get that
without reminders so you got to set up
alarms or triggers or some you know no
cards around that whatever it is it
takes for you to have that but i know
for me
raise after the research
i didn't get how
i mean i mean you're talking from every
athlete to every high ceo this is what
they did
there
and i didn't find this you'll see all
the questions i asked them in the book i
really had to dial in their psyche
and when we found that i was like is
that a thing
that they'd really that's i mean but
they all do and so it inspired me to
level them i'm going to raise my
necessity and i'll i'm going to practice
everything in the book to get that up a
little higher how about number three be
more present with ed mylett i've made a
mistake in my life and that is it's it's
contrary to what i teach i've not been
great in my life at being present
i've not been great at it i think a lot
of achievers struggle with this and i go
in and out of this mode where if i was
in the was at the pool yesterday with my
kids
and i'm looking at him and max is going
to college this year
my daughter's like a young woman now you
know and
i wish when they were a little younger
that those moments when we were in the
pool when they were younger i was just
with them i'm not thinking about work
and thinking about protecting them and
thinking about saving for college and
being in the moment and enjoying now
right like really enjoying now and the
moments i'm the most effective the most
blissful the most joyful spreading it is
what i'm the most present and i've
always struggled with that because i'm
always dreaming about the future and
wanting to achieve in the future the
best me is the one when you're just me
and you are in the backyard you know i'm
hanging out
and it's just me and you louis and and
so for me i go back to the 30 year old
and i'd say i want you to achieve i want
you to win please enjoy this moment
please be present right now the 40 year
old louis
with this beautiful relationship you're
in now and all the achievement don't
miss now for what the possibilities are
in the future like enjoy now if this
moment right now with the corona crisis
teaches us all anything it's like all we
really have is right now
and the more you project into the future
you know i said in my post today on
instagram i said or on all social media
i said you know worrying doesn't solve
today's problems it takes away today's
piece
and and and and i so i that's most of my
posts are lessons for me so that would
be my lesson at 30 40 and 50 is
be more present be
you can't love yourself if you're not
being yourself just be you just be
present how about number four customize
your life with gorga paul das get
consumed by the positive energy
focus
not on your bad habits
get consumed not by the negative energy
of your bad habit sometimes we just get
so consumed by that all that's playing
on our mind is that
no
that's meant to be dealt with
focus
on the good things that are happening in
your life
and to focus on the good things and be
grateful doesn't happen automatically
it's not our default setting our default
setting is to go towards the negative
our default setting is it to focus on
the negative
we have to customize our lives
by being consciously aware
we have to become more mindful and
conscious
of the wonderful
gifts the wonderful opportunities the
wonderful blessings that we've been
showered with
and with that
positive energy
with that positive emotion of gratitude
feel
tremendously empowered
to deal with our bad habits to deal with
our challenges
and therefore
do not be hateful about what you're
going through in life
be grateful
for all those
wonderful gifts that you've been given
in your life
all of us got up this morning
many in the world did not get up
they left this world they died last
night
probably with their bad habits probably
with their challenges probably with
their difficulties and troubled
situations
all of us got up we pray for those who
left
we wish well for all those who left last
night
we all got up
and we have to be grateful
for that second chance that we have been
given
for that second opportunity that we've
been given
to transform
to change
to live a better life
and to help others live a better life
and therefore
the reflection that i want to leave all
of you with
today is get consumed by gratitude the
positive emotion of gratitude don't be
hateful about your life be grateful for
all the wonderful things that are
happening in your life focus on the
positive and deal with the negative
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there how about number five stop
overthinking with dean graziosi i want
to encourage each and every one of you
to do the video you've been thinking
about doing
to do one for whether you're in real
estate you're a lawyer you're in life
coaching
do a video to help sell what you do
write a letter write a sales letter
start your marketing start your
advertising scale the company you have
finally start the business and stop
overthinking
what your marketing and sales copy and
training is going to be like and start
living from your heart people want real
now more than ever before in history
with the way our government is president
is people just want it like it is i
think we're done with the hype the hype
we had hype in the 80s we had hype you
know 15 years ago and we're having a
hype now no one wants hype they want
what's real so i want to tell you there
couldn't be a better time to scale your
business start your business or use
these same strategies with the people
you work with so you can grow within
your company how about number six be
prepared with david goggins for me my
routine is every night i stretch out and
i stretch out for two or three hours
every single night without fail yeah and
while i'm stretching out i'm thinking
about
my plan for the next day
now i'm thinking about all these
different obstacles that may come up so
basically a lot of us aren't prepared
for life
we get up willy-nilly and just hope life
is going to happen
it is going to happen but it's going to
happen with the prepared mind or
unprepared mind most people attack life
with the unprepared mind
what i do is i try to account for
all things that could happen might
happen probably will happen and then the
unknowns
so basically
i can't account for
everything
but i do know there could be some things
that come up in life that you need to be
ready for i know for a fact i'm not
going to want to work out tomorrow
therefore i'm preparing my mind for that
i don't want to do that i know tomorrow
will come with some difficult decisions
to make it may come with
a getting a phone call saying someone
died
this happened that happened i'm always
preparing myself not in a morbid way
but just like look man be ready for life
don't let life just start attacking you
left and right make sure that you start
to build a mental armor
so then you're ready for life and that
comes with a very
physical way
and the physical helps out to mental
habit number seven practice emotional
resilience with mel robbins often times
when you hit bottom you bounce
and that's where i think the power is
that you when the world feels upside
down you always have the power to make
it right when one chapter ends you
always have the power to write a new one
when you know you feel like nobody loves
you you have the power to learn how to
love yourself and if there's one thing
that covid 19 has done regardless of
whatever devastation it has caused in
your life is it has forced us all
to experience the great pause
and
i read that in a medium article and i
love that idea of a pause because i
think in 2020 our lives have gotten so
fast and so digital and
when you are forced to pause and get
present and to slow down
you are reminded
of what's actually important
and what's important is your health
what's important is your family and your
friends
what's important is whether or not you
are taking care of yourself and thinking
positive thoughts versus negative
thoughts the world gave us a gigantic
experiment where we got to practice and
get to continue to practice the most
important skill in the planet which is
emotional resilience the ability to face
hard
and actually be okay
the ability to face the uncertain
and
redirect your attention on things that
you know
that are certain habit number eight
don't be distracted with les brown in
life
what we're doing right now
it is to me
an experiment with life
there's so much noise in this world
and most people never achieve their
goals because of the noise
because it is so distracting
one of my students her name is
stacy nc grant and she wrote a book
called action action
despite the distractions
and so what most people do they stop and
they look around the reason
that lot you know was saying don't look
back
is because you become paralyzed when you
allow yourself to be distracted and
seduced by the noise of life that you
have to discipline yourself the road to
life is straight and narrow and few
there be that find it because few there
be that are willing to focus their minds
where focus goes energy flows
that are willing to discipline
themselves
and
and as a result
most people allow their dreams their
potential
their goals to be derailed
because they take their eyes off of what
it is that they're at
how about number nine stop making
excuses with rachel hollis why excuses
and skills because that well the excuses
are just what i hear all day from women
in dms and emails standing in line at a
book signing it's all the reasons why
they can't do what they want to do and
um
makes my head explode because it's like
what like you're not oh
it drives me crazy so i thought it's
well and good for us to talk about the
things that you need to do to achieve
this stuff but none of this matters if
you don't have this foundational
like presence of mind to get out of your
own way and to stop using that as a
crutch for why you can't
do what you want to do if i get flack
for anything in this space it's the idea
that i tell women that anybody can
accomplish anything and i really believe
that to the marrow of my bones because
there is no reason that i should have
the life that i have the business i've
built the
being on state like i shouldn't have any
of this this is
working
every single day for the last 15 years
to achieve the thing that i want to
achieve you had said something recently
or maybe it was on your instagram where
someone said like how do i become a
speaker and you were like speak
everywhere everyone go everywhere
that
people like oh i would love to be a
speaker but i can never talk like you
and i'm like
i spoke at old folks homes i spoke
because they can't run away by the way
if anyone needs this tip the people
laugh i'm like no was for real mops
groups which is mothers of preschoolers
they exist all over the country
i'd speak at the opening of an envelope
and i was horrible like my first
speeches it was this maybe something it
was like
and it's so embarrassing and you know
your hands are shaking and i had note
cards and i keep the videos on youtube
because i want people to see the
progression of what a decade looks like
i've done it so much and you need me to
do a keynote right now i got you i can
make it up
but it didn't start that way it was so
many years and so much effort and the
problem is
people don't they're like well i can't
because or here's the reason why i'm
like yeah me too
i had all those excuses and it didn't
mean that making the decision to move
forward suddenly it got easier
if anything making the decision to move
forward is harder like because now um
john maxwell said this to me the other
day he's like which is the most named
drop you think but i was interviewing
him on the podcast we're not like you
know having a slumber party but he said
um movement causes friction
always and so it's you it just because
you make the decision to move forward
doesn't mean it you know now we're now
we're doing it no now you've got all
kinds of other problems so excuses were
really important for me to tackle just
because
i i think
love my girls but women especially like
we need to call bs and you need to have
someone
get in your face and say like with all
the love in my heart this is not this is
not real this is something that you've
decided to cling to because it justifies
why you're still in the same place and
habit number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is be confident
with mike tyson while i'm in the
dressing room five minutes before i come
out my gloves are laced up i'm breaking
my gloves down i'm broke i'm pushing the
lever in the back of my break in the
middle of the glove so my knuckle
appears through the leg i feel my
knuckle piercing against the tight
leather gloves on the everlast boxing
glove when i come out i have supreme
confidence but i'm scared to death
i'm totally afraid i'm afraid of
everything i'm afraid of losing i'm
afraid of being humiliated but i'm
totally confident closer i get to ring
the more confidence i get the closer
more confidence i get the closer more
confidence i get all during my training
i've been afraid of this man i thought
this man might be capable of beating me
i've dreamed of him beating me
but that well but i always stayed afraid
of him but it was closer i get to the
ring i'm more confident once i'm in the
ring i'm a god no one could beat me
i walk around the ring but i never i
never take my eyes off my opponent i
keep my eyes on him even if he's ready
and pumping he can't wait to get his
hands on me as well i keep my eyes on
him i keep my arizona i keep my eyes on
him then once i see a [ __ ] in his arm
boom and one of his eyes may move and
then i know i have him then when he
comes to the center of the ring he still
looks at me with his piercing look and
as if he's not afraid but he already
made that mistake when he when he looked
down for that one tenth of a second i
know i had him he'll fight hard for the
first two or three rounds i know i
already broke his spirit
during the fight i'm supremely confident
i'm moving my head he's throwing punches
i'm making a mess and i'm countering i'm
hitting him to the body i'm punching him
real hard and i'm punching and when i'm
punching him i know he's not able to
take my punches one two three punches
i'm throwing him up punches and bunches
he goes down he's out i'm victorious
mike tyson greatest fighter ever lived
now i've got a special bonus clip that i
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the good deed of the day
this is something new i believe that
you're able to serve and it feels so
good to do something nice for somebody
else so good deed of the day put down in
the comments one thing that you need
help with that you're working on you'd
love some support or guidance on and
then two go comment on somebody else's
comment and give them some love give
them some support give them some
encouragement maybe give them some
connections try to help them solve that
problem even if it's saying i believe in
you that one little bit of encouragement
can be the difference between somebody
quitting and continuing on so the good
deed of the day in the comments below
write down one thing that you need help
on that you're struggling with that
you're working on and then part two is
go give love to somebody else in the
comments too and let them know that you
believe in them as well you have the
power to control your world how you
think how you act your mindset with the
words that you speak when you use weak
language you signal to yourself that you
are weak you signal to yourself that
your goals aren't important you signal
to yourself that you are not worth it
you lose respect for yourself and the
people around you don't respect you
either we need to stop using weak
language and pay attention to the words
that you're speaking to others and to
yourself
now this is not an easy task because
most of the words that you're using the
way that you talk to others into
yourself you're on autopilot you're on
cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades and
so switching it is not going to happen
overnight but if you pay attention to
the next three things that i'm going to
share with you it can have a dramatic
impact on your self-confidence and the
goals that you have for yourself and on
the outcomes you create for yourself and
the world let's do it number one i can't
i'm not i don't what you say after those
three things shapes your identity it
speaks to how you think and speak about
yourself so i can't i can't be an
entrepreneur i can't be a leader i can't
be a youtuber i can't i can't i can't i
can't i can't especially this one when
you say i can't pay very very very very
very very close attention to what
follows and try
and try and try to shift it
from i can't to either i choose not to
or i can't
yet i'm not i'm not a good salesperson
i'm not funny i'm not the kind of person
who follows through again pay close
attention and try to shift it to not yet
i don't
i don't program i don't know how to make
money i don't think like that
switch i don't do i don't yet
i can't i'm not i don't those statements
are final those statements don't allow
for growth those statements are how you
feel about yourself and don't allow for
the stretch they don't allow you to get
better and so either eliminate them from
your vocabulary or change them to yet
number two is catch your cruise control
the way that you have been speaking
about yourself the way that you have
been talking to yourself has been
happening using the same words for years
maybe even decades it's so automatic for
you you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself without even
thinking about it you need to catch your
cruise control and listen don't be too
hard on yourself this is so ingrained
these patterns have been around for so
long you are just auto defaulting to
cruise control that most of these times
you will not even catch it you will not
catch 99
of these moments of these words of these
languages that you're using for yourself
but if you have the awareness if you
have the intention if you have the
desire every now and then you will catch
it another quick hack is to enlist a
friend and list the people around you
your wife your husband your team your
kids kids especially my son hayden loves
calling me out on things enlist their
help tell them this is where i want to
play a bigger game this is where i'm
frustrated with myself this is where i
keep talking badly about myself and
putting myself down these are the words
the language that need to change and
every time you hear me talking this way
i need you to bring it to my awareness
and let me know because i want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime i complain i
want my wife i want my team i want my
son i want the people around me to say
evan you are complaining right there
that was a complaint eat it right i'm
happy for them to hug me with it to yell
at me with it i just want them to let me
know now when i told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you i'm humbled but i
still complain and i probably complain a
lot and a lot of the times i'm missing
it and so please please please please
please please please even if you think
i'm great at it if you catch me
complaining i want you to call me out on
it so enlisting your friends can be
really helpful because you will likely
not catch most of them yourself but it's
imperative that you start working on
catching your cruise control step number
three is manual override you have caught
your cruise control you have found the
autopilot it's about to happen again
this negative talk that you're about to
speak out into the world about yourself
for your ideas you putting yourself down
is about to come out again or has just
come out
what do you do about it because this is
really important
if you catch yourself playing smaller
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it
and you don't do anything it actually
makes it worse
it's better that you don't even catch it
at all
if you catch it and you recognize i am
playing small right now
and you ignore it and you don't change
your behavior you are building that
identity for yourself that you are
somebody who is plain small
you are consciously building that
identity for yourself and you need to
stop it
it makes it worse
where when you do catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore whether you find it
yourself or somebody's calling you out
on it
what do you do you need to kick your
manual override into action and take the
action that you want because that starts
building the positive habit that starts
building the positive respect this is
how you build respect for yourself this
is how you start building the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to neutral
when you catch it you either go sliding
down or you go propelling up
the choice is yours when you catch
yourself playing small when you catch
yourself coming off a cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up and speak positively
about yourself and do the thing that you
are scared to do how many times have you
had somebody say to you hey have you got
a minute but
you got a minute
they don't want a minute
i want you to think about that
i read a poem one time i said i have
only just a minute only 60 seconds in it
it was forced upon me i can't refuse it
i didn't seek it and i didn't choose it
but it's up to me to use it i must
suffer if i lose it give a count if i
abuse it it's only a tiny little minute
but eternity is in it
well anyway i thought i'm going to put
this on a video and i'm just going to
share with everybody just this one
little part of the seminar i'm making
i want you to look at this sam timer and
let this i want you to think about your
life the sand in the top of the glass
represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past
now do you know we know what's in the
past and yet we can't do anything about
it do you know what the trick is you
don't know how much sands in the top of
the glass you may think you have a lot
you might only have a little
then again you may think you have a
little and you might have a lot
when i was a little boy i was raised by
my grandmother
and i don't know when i was little
gaffer she was probably 60 but
as long as i could remember grandma
would say and i'll soon be glenn dear
i'll soon be gone well you know we loved
her she was really an angel of god but
we thought she was never going to go she
lived to be 94 for 30 some years
i'll soon be gone
she didn't think she had much time left
she had 34 years left
now about the same time i had a buddy of
mine bob yates he was just 16.
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out
if you had asked him a half hour before
how much sandy had left he would have
said at least a half a century he didn't
have a half an hour
see the trick is we don't know how much
sand we have left
the future
we don't know the past it's gone now the
only thing you can deal with is what's
right here right now and if you look the
sand is always moving
now think of this
you see i was working on that and then i
was working on a graph i've got here on
my computer
and i'm thinking of the time somebody
said have you got a minute
well they don't really want a minute
do you know if you're earning 50 000 a
year in minutes 42 cents
a half hour is 12.50
if we take that ahead of it if you're
earning 80 000 a year a minute 67 cents
half hours 20 dollars
if you're earning a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
it cost you a dollar 25 a minute
a half hour's 37 dollars and 50 cents so
if you see if somebody said you wanna
stop for a cup of coffee
well
if you're earning a quarter of a million
dollars a year
a minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hour is 62.50
and then of course you got the coffee to
pay for on top of that
so you see
the point is this
this is all we've got right here right
now we don't know how much we have left
in the future but we do know what we've
got now and i have found the people that
win
are the people who make up their mind
they're not going to waste the minutes
they're going to be productive they're
going to make it happen
every minute every day we recharge our
phones but we forget to recharge
ourselves
let's just say we slept well the night
before which means we start our day with
a hundred percent charge
when we wake up in the morning we roll
over and eighty percent of us check our
smartphones before we brush our teeth we
scroll through social media we browse
through emails
that takes away ten percent of our
energy
let's say we now have
90
charge left we then commute to work we
spend our day in the office in meetings
interacting with colleagues finishing
off projects and assignments we now have
40 percent charge left
on the way home we commute through
traffic or on the train and that takes
away another let's say 10
we now have 30 percent charge left
we come home and switch on netflix talk
to someone about what our day was like
and sometimes we lose another 10 percent
we now have 20 percent charge left at 20
on our phones usually the charge bar
goes red we get an alert we get a
message that tells us that we only have
20 battery left the question is do we
notice when our charge is at 20 percent
or 10 percent there are always signs
from our bodies our brains our minds but
are we tuned in one of the best things
we can do to recharge is to exercise the
hardest part of any workout is actually
the 15 minutes leading up to it we come
up with 15 reasons why we don't want to
sweat and we change our mind 15
different times cnn reports that when
you work out your brain creates more
serotonin which sends messages to your
nervous system of happiness and
well-being working out for 30 to 40
minutes every day can recharge our
battery by 20
meditation is an incredible way to
recharge our batteries
exactly what the gym does for the body
meditation can do for the mind
meditation gives us down time physically
mentally emotionally and spiritually
meditation also directly impacts your
entire nervous system by reducing your
body's productions of stress-related
chemicals such as cortisol
meditation is a great way to recharge
and can take you back up 20
we've all heard about incredible morning
routines but the one thing that can make
a huge difference to your recharge is
your evening routine 35 of us are not
getting the recommended seven hours of
sleep per night remember every body and
mind is different make sure you find the
amount of time you need to get that
serious battery recharge and the 75-year
study by harvard found that beyond
anything
the real sense check for happiness and
meaning in life
was relationships connections
interactions with depth that are
fulfilling and full of joy making time
for deep meaningful interactions every
day can give the recharge our battery
seriously needs
what if we've recharged ourselves
as much as we recharge our phones
because if we don't we'll end up like
one of our phones
in the bottom of some drawer in our home
i have this thing that i've been
promoting called no whining wednesdays
wednesday you cannot whine
complain or criticize
and people like well what is whining
whatever you think it is don't do it
and every time you do it you have to put
a quarter in a jar
if you whine about anything i can't i'm
tired why do me you want one why don't
you what happened
every one of them will cost you a
quarter
or complaining why don't you why do you
always how come you i always they never
cost you a quarter
then last week i had people send me
pictures of their jaws or quarters
oh my god
but what they said to me also was this
was wonderful because i was never ever
aware
of how much whining and complaining and
criticizing i do
now i've got mothers
doing it with their children
so wednesday is no whining wednesday
we need to practice that
we need to stop
whining
about what isn't happening what we don't
have what we can't do what somebody
didn't do
we got to get it clean in 2014
no whining
no complaining
no criticizing i try to be over prepared
in some sense so i mean i believe that
if you're going to if you're going to
give a 20-minute lecture you should have
an hour of material at hand because that
way you have an opportunity to sort of
move spontaneously through the material
but generally what i do now because i
have a lot of material
at hand a lot of stories and a lot of
things that i've acknowledged say that
i've accrued over the years usually
before a lecture also and this is the
hard part and i can do a lecture without
doing this but it's better if i do this
this is the hard part i'll sit down for
20 minutes with my eyes closed
and i figure out what the what the
central topic is so there's always a
question what's the question i'm trying
to address in this lecture
and then i'll figure out a pathway
through it it's like okay well here's
the argument here's point one here's
point two here's point three and there's
possible branches off those and then
with each point i usually have a
collection of stories and facts that i
can use to
make the point that'll make the point
yeah and then to buttress it and to make
it interesting and so it's a little bit
it's a little bit like
improvisational jazz i would say or even
improvisational piano because i play a
little bit of piano one so you lay out
the the story and then right you can use
the responses of the audience to guide
how you're going to walk through it the
simple part
that most people don't understand is
that every thought we think in every
word we speak
is creating our future
it's as though our thoughts go out into
the universe and are
accepted and brought back to us as
experience
now that is a very simple thing but most
people don't get it they don't
understand it they've never heard it
before and they think it's ridiculous
but if you can really accept the fact
that every time you think a thought and
every time you speak a word you are
literally painting your future making
your dinner whatever you want to call it
you are creating
and you're creating your own life
and this is simple
but it's not easy
to accept but once you accept it then
you can start deliberately
creating what you want in your life
and you begin to be aware
of what you don't want in your life and
how you are contributing to it
now i think this has been around forever
but for some reason in the last 20 years
the universe has wanted this to go out
among all the people or all the people
that are ready for it
see most of us just think they think
think think think think and we don't pay
any attention to what we're thinking
we're just doing it but that's something
you need to train yourself to do to
begin to train yourself to be aware of
what you're thinking
and and one of the ways to do that is to
periodically say to yourself what am i
thinking
would i like this thought to create my
life
would i like to have the experience that
this thought could bring to me
now it takes a while to do that but even
if we could begin on the smallest level
to be aware of our thinking we can start
to make changes i went from scrounging
my couch cushions to find enough change
to put gas in my car
to helping build this technology company
i was hired as a copywriter and i worked
my way up i became a multi-millionaire
inside that company on paper
and i was
miserable
miserable
and i thought this is a joke i'm living
the cliche of money camp by happiness
what how many people had to say it and i
still didn't believe it like how many
people literally have to tell you money
is not going to give you the thing you
want i've had every opportunity up here
to be like yeah just get rich
that [ __ ] is cool as hell
and here's the thing people will chase
money forever why because it's real
money is real money is powerful
but money's not at all what you think it
is you think when it comes to success
like getting there making it achieving
it the way that you see somebody that's
achieved it now however you define that
and you look at them and you think oh my
god they're amazing you think you're
gonna think the same thing about
yourself
and you won't
and i had the very good fortune my
wealth came all at once
i built a company i had tons of equity
in the company i was worth hundreds of
millions of dollars on paper but i was
still driving a beat-up car and my life
was whatever i was in a normal house i
was making a good salary no need to feel
sorry for me but in terms of like
the wealth moment it literally came in
an instant
it was all right guys the money's been
wired
and you hit refresh on your bank account
refresh refresher faster faster fresh
professional fresh and then bam you're
crazy rich and it's like
commas and zeros and you're like holy
[ __ ]
i don't feel any differently about
myself
and all of my insecurities all the
things that i beat myself up for all of
it still right here it literally didn't
change anything i could buy neater stuff
but the only thing like if you want to
know what money really does
money lets you build
i'm building impact theory
i'm going to win
because i have the intensity
and i have the
capital that's money but money doesn't
touch who you are so my thing is i may
go broke building
impact theory that that is a reality
because i know the struggle is
guaranteed the success isn't
so it's very possible i'm betting my
fortune right now
on building this thing maybe it doesn't
work
but that won't touch how i feel about
myself
losing the money won't touch how i feel
about myself any more than making the
money couldn't touch how i felt about
myself because you either do the
internal work of like i know who i am
the thing that you'll resent
isn't whether or not you make it
the thing that you'll resent is now that
you know you can will you actually try
trying is what you're going to judge
yourself on
hey don't cheer on that that [ __ ] is
scary that's the one i want you guys to
think about today
because none of you
your family won't weep for you if you
don't succeed
two things will happen on your deathbed
if you failed you really went for
something and you failed
one
they will all mourn that you weren't
able to live your life because you were
so myopically focused on the goal
that you forgot to enjoy the journey
and somewhere along the way you stopped
loving you stopped loving them you
stopped loving yourself because all you
could see
was succeeding getting that thing the
tick on the paper box
and you lost your way that's possibility
number one
possibility number two
is they're like hey
this
tried and it was inspiring and just to
see them go
day after day after day in the face of
so much defeat but to have the will and
determination to keep going
winston churchill said and i quote
success is going from failure
to failure
to failure
without a loss of enthusiasm
it doesn't matter if you win that's not
success
the success is going from the failure to
the failure to the failure and still
being excited to show up
it's like this is how i liken success
success is like love you know the
beautiful part about love getting the
[ __ ] kicked out of you and then
coming back for more
that's so hopeful that's so optimistic
to be like whoa i just had my ass handed
to me and yet i want to be vulnerable
again i want to go through this again i
want to open myself up to this i want to
be touched by that i want to feel that
people can get behind that man we can
get excited about that
we want to be friends with people like
that we want to feel that in our own
lives that willingness to to have tasted
defeat
and still come in open and not jaded how
beautiful is that i
started to retrain my brain at 19 years
old and it opened up the world of
success to me in health wealth
relationships career business
fun experiences and then i started to
teach it to my employees
yeah
you know in re max
back in 1992 i hit a wonderful plateau
where i hit you know 1.2 billion dollars
in sales and people go well that's great
i said but that wasn't the ceiling for
what our possibilities were and so no
matter how much i trained
our real estate agent had a thousand
five hundred of them or we grew two
thousand five i may have had maybe a
thousand two hundred at the time but we
we stopped teaching them how to sell
more real estate
and we started working on retraining
their brains retraining their financial
set point retraining their expectancy
point retraining how they thought about
prospecting retraining how they thought
about doing the high income and the high
impact activities and over the course of
the next four years we increased our
sales by 3.3
billion dollars
you what
increased our sales
by
3.3
billion dollars to four and a half
billion a year in sales
why
because we
reset the agent's expectancy point the
average real estate agent at the time
was making about 30 40 000 a year in the
industry
our agent's average was
128 000 per person average
and i'm going back i'm going back quite
a while
yeah and then i did the same thing with
bamboo.com and we grew that from six
people to 1500 in 14 months to 10
million a month in revenue in the ninth
month and did a successful ipo on nasdaq
it wasn't because we were the smartest
kids on the block
but we trained our team to think at a
higher level to be able to overcome the
doubts and the fears and the anxieties
that hold most people back how did you
get that mentality of just being like i
need to get over this like i need to get
over myself you know trial and error
you know you grow up and you make game
winning shots and it's awesome you come
back the next day and miss a game when
it's shot and it's misery and then the
next day comes and you're back playing
again and you understand that life has
this cyclical nature where it's you know
what you do on monday it's fantastic but
then tuesday's a bad day but guess what
there's wednesday so are we just
supposed to live our lives like this the
whole time
you know versus just staying like this
and understanding that it's really just
a journey of
evolution every day it's just constant
improvement constant curiosity
constantly getting better the results
don't really matter
uh it's the figuring out
that matters yeah and we all get
obsessed about the results yeah like we
get obsessed about like the output yeah
not the input of not figuring it out and
not like changing things well you said
trial and error like the experimenting
yeah we forget to do that it's
unfortunate man like i've seen a lot of
players um especially now and you know
in youth basketball dealing with that
um you have players that are like bigger
and faster and stronger and you know
their coaches are just coaching them for
results you know we're just going to use
your size that because you're bigger
than every other 12 year old out there
to dominate today
but they're not growing
right so they're just based on that
result but they're not focused on
growing this young child yeah into
becoming a better athlete and through
that teaching them how to become a more
well-rounded person
and we're missing that many of the
things that people use to try and help
them sleep inadvertently are actually
harming and hurting their sleep
two good examples are probably alcohol
and marijuana
many people will
have a little night cap in the evening
and they think that having a drink in
the evening helps them fall asleep it's
actually not true
alcohol is a class of drugs that we call
the sedatives and sedation is not sleep
so what you're doing when you drink in
the evening is actually just knocking
out your cortex and you're going into
this
sedation-like state you're not going
into natural sleep there are two other
problems with alcohol unfortunately and
i'm so sorry to be giving you this bad
news but
um firstly alcohol will actually litter
your sleep with many more awakenings
throughout the night
and so you you won't feel restored when
you wake up the next morning by your
sleep you won't feel refreshed
the problem and the danger is that many
people don't remember waking up so much
throughout the night when they've been
drinking
so they don't realize that it was the
alcohol disrupting their sleep they
don't put two and two together the final
thing about alcohol is that it's very
good at blocking your rem sleep or your
dream sleep rapid eye movement sleep and
we know that rem sleep is essential for
a variety of functions including
emotional and mental health
and so alcohol will actually remove that
dream sleep or it will decrease it
significantly blocking that essential
critical sleep i should also note by the
way how essential is that rem sleep well
studies done back in the 1980s some
really quite shocking studies
demonstrated that if you deprive rats of
rapid eye movement sleep they will die
almost as quickly as they would from
total food deprivation that's how
essential that dream sleep is and it's
that dream sleep that you block with
alcohol
what about though marijuana
well
unfortunately the news isn't so great
there a lot of people will again help
will use marijuana to help them relax
and sort of just take away some of that
anxiety that's preventing them from
falling asleep and certainly marijuana
does seem to hasten the speed with which
you fall asleep but unfortunately
marijuana like alcohol but through
actually a different biological
mechanism will also block your dream
sleep and if you're not getting that
critical rem sleep you can actually
become more anxious even more depressed
the following day and therefore people
start to seek out more marijuana to sort
of medicate those symptoms that the
marijuana is causing because of the
sleep disruption the next one is
organization i can't tell you how much
better my life is and anybody watching
this will be if you wake up every single
day
and you take 10 minutes i have yellow
notepad sitting all around my house i
got that from bill gates bill gates bill
microsoft at 17 by locking himself in a
hotel room with six yellow notepads and
he wrote out the whole basic code for
dos and things that built microsoft okay
he became the richest man in the world
18 years straight because he was
organized enough to lock himself in a
room
and think through his day and so what i
try to do and whenever i do this i have
a great day whenever i don't
i notice it
be organized a little bit 10 minutes i
actually have this little couch thing
outside of my shower and i put a notepad
by it i take a shower when i wake up i
walk over to that i kind of sit there
and i just write out i mean it can be as
little as three main projects you want
to get done that day i live with within
my means i don't
know like
rolls royces 10 rolls races lamborghinis
ferraris um
10 like i manchester have all that stuff
so it doesn't really hasn't changed that
aspect
but it just made me realize um it helps
me
in terms of certain conversations i'm
having and the reputation i carry is
more important than what's in the bank
because i was i've been around like
like i'm talking billionaires
and um it's not so much about their
money it's about their character because
when when it's about their money
all of us are sitting here with a
million pound in our account
you have the watch i have you have the
car i have and you have the house i have
so yeah materialistic things are
they're available to madrid people at
every level so then it became about
character models what you stand for
um your manners and that's why and your
respect and integrity so that's more
what is valued in that
economic structure than
just money you know i mean you have to
learn and that's what i say your respect
takes you further because what got me
through a lot of doors isn't
is it money it was honestly character
back in the day
mostly about character so is this a
fight for old school classic games new
money then every time he's in a straight
guard you're saying class this is i'm
gonna go around him as well but there is
an element of it where he will learn
that
money don't make you man make some money
money doesn't make it bad my dad used to
always say when you form a habit that
habit forms you
good or bad and really the best people
in the world are a collection of great
habits i think we've seen with athletes
like tiger woods if you get away from
those habits no matter what your
aptitude is you're going to be average
or below average
so with russ every year it's about just
sustaining great habits he understands
that he doesn't need to be sick to get
better
he's won more games than anybody in the
history of pro football in his first
four years and every off season uh two
years ago it was down in san diego this
year it was in l.a it's just about
where should we be eating training who
are the best people to be around and as
good as we are how do we get better and
that's kind of the support we do it's
not there's nothing broken everything's
about uh continuous improvement my thing
is how do we stay alive long enough to
give time for these step function
breakthroughs to happen so
what do i do like what are the things
that i train or the hormone replacement
therapies that i need to go what do i
need to watch what are those things that
i should be doing
taking a step back i would say three
years ago 80 to 90 of my energy went
into how to not die
which basically is a strategy yeah which
is tantamount to how do you delay the
onset of chronic disease so the
mathematical equivalent of longevity
from a lifespan perspective is creating
a phase shift in disease onset
if you want to live to a hundred it
basically means you have to delay the
onset by about two decades of every
major chronic disease so it doesn't mean
you can't get cancer or heart disease or
any of these other things but you better
figure out a way to get them 20 years
after the average person gets them
i would say now that occupies 50 percent
of my brain wave energy whatever and
much more time goes into two other
things which is how to minimize
suffering which is kind of an emotional
problem and then how to be this kick-ass
100 year old so to the latter
um
the model i have in my mind is that of
sort of bruce lee bruce lee
sort of looked at each and every
discipline of martial arts including
boxing and wrestling and things like
that and said
let me extract from each of these
disciplines that which i believe is
useful discard those that i think are
useless and create a perfect fighting
form that is truly geared towards
self-defense so it is not a sport there
is no tournament there is no rank there
is no belt there is no sensei it is can
you handle yourself in a life or death
situation
if i go to a yoga class
or if i do a pilates class invariably
there's something in there that i think
is really valuable and truthfully
there's a bunch of stuff that i'm like i
don't need this this is just if i had
infinite time this would be fine to do
but i don't have infinite time
so now you apply a constraint to the
problem which is not only do you want to
be sort of the best 100 year old
imaginable what if you're only willing
to spend 10 to 12 hours a week preparing
for that
and so you say okay well so there's a
new sport which we defined some of the
parameters of that's your new olympics
and that olympics is 50 years from now
how will you train for it if you're only
willing to spend 10 to 12 hours a week
training for it
well my guess is you will take a lot of
things
from various disciplines discard a lot
of things and sort of have to build a
very bespoke
routine around it that will involve the
maintenance of muscle mass joint
integrity flexibility
functional movement balance things that
we don't even really think about anymore
how many times does someone who's 90
fall because they've lost their balance
and it's that fall that ultimately leads
to their demise i'll try says i'll make
a feeble attempt i will is absolute
non-negotiable no matter what there's a
certain energy that goes forth when you
say i'll try and there's a different
energy that goes forth when you say i
will when you make the declaration of i
will that says mountain if you are there
you must move
i'll try says i hope i got enough energy
to make it up or around the mountain and
if not i'm gonna sit at the bottom of
the hill
when you fail to make a plan okay well
hold on this might hit you between the
eyes you know i love you but when you
fail to make a clear concrete plan that
has goals and milestones meaning they're
smaller goals that you can hit to get to
the bigger goal and has a by win date
not in february not in august but august
15th
by 5 pm
eastern standard time yeah when i set a
goal i even want to know the time zone
and have it done by clarity
when you fail to make a plan with clear
distinction when you fail to make a
clear plan
you have clearly planned to fail
i'll say it again
when you fail to make a clear plan
then you've clearly planned to fail i
know that hits you hard i've done it
many times i have clearly planned to
fail many times because i had an idea
and it was just in my unconscious i
didn't know now i want to bring to you
what i know to you so you know it i want
you to make a clear plan when you create
a clear plan then you're clearly
planning to succeed there are many
aspects to this fundamentally if you
keep your life energies very exuberant
now you will see the sleep quota will
naturally come down to keep it exuberant
you should not be overlad
largely
in the ashram everybody young people
also eat only two meals a day ten in the
morning seven in the evening
our activity
exceeds most people's activity in the
world and we are seven days 365 days we
don't know what's a vacation because
we're enjoying what we're doing
we don't want a break
so
they never go on a vacation there is no
break there's no sunday monday nonsense
nothing every day something is happening
endlessly
but you will see
people are very energetic healthy sleep
is very little
so energetically a human being can be at
different levels why this is important
is
see what we call as life is just a
combination of two things
a certain amount of energy and a certain
amount of time
when it comes to time
it is ticking away for all of us at the
same pace clock doesn't run slowly for
me faster for you there's no such thing
whether you are busy you're lazy you're
sleeping you're doing useful things or
useless things it doesn't matter what
you do or you do not do
time is ticking away
so there's no such thing as time
management
you can manage your energy
if you raise your energy to a higher
pitch of intensity
what somebody does in 10 years you may
do it in one year
so if you live for 100 years it looks
like you lived for a thousand years
simply because your energy is pitched up
this every human being can do
the whole yogic system is one dimension
of yogic system is just towards this if
you sit here even if you simply sit here
with your eyes closed you don't sit here
in a static way
you sit here in a dynamic way
you never become static because static
is called as death
if everything becomes static that is
death if inertia really sets in that is
death
so sleep in yoga is seen as death
you die every day
how long do you want to die in a day
you really must use this word for
yourself don't tell anybody i'm going to
die
for yourself how long do i want to die
in a day
eight hours a day if you die
one third of your life you're dead
in 24 hours eight hours you're dead
means one third of your life dead
another four hours goes into eating
sleeping eating toilet bath this that
where is the time to live i'm asking
so if life is precious
the most important thing to do is keep
your energies in an exuberant way so
that
life becomes more life feels enhanced
because you cannot enhance time i made
it a habit to listen as much as i could
and because i have many great mentors
i would
understand from them that the way they
built their lives they built their
careers also came from this listening
so i started listening and what i
started to find is that very often
the messages don't just come
from an intuitive impulse or an insight
it comes from a random person whom we
meet on the street or it comes from a
random conversation here in this room or
it comes from a book that we pick up in
the morning
literally some of the ideas i'm going to
share from stage today came from these
random encounters over the last 24 hours
i'm going to share an idea that came
from a book today like a really thick
book that a friend gave me last night
i asked the universe is there a message
in this book that i should share with
the audience i open the page and boom
there it was
and the basis for this talk came from a
mysterious phone call that came to me
yesterday morning
so yesterday morning i was brushing my
teeth
and i was asking myself
what do i talk about 24 hours from now
on stage
and i didn't want to just tap into my
logical brain and look at my file of
like some 50 different regular
presentations i thought maybe i'll just
go take the elevator down randomly roam
the lobby and wait for one of you guys
to approach me and ask me a question
carry out a conversation and see what
happens because that's how the universe
sometimes speaks to you
right um the universe doesn't have
whatsapp so it basically like
manipulates people to come into your
life i would hide in the tower books
section
in the evenings and i would read
everything about fitness psychology
anything i could i've always devoured
information my favorite book when i was
a kid was the encyclopedia or the
guinness book of worlds records so i
would like when i was a little kid i'd
walk around the aspen center for physics
and i would tell anyone i didn't even
ask them if they wanted to hear about
like the what's the world's smallest
eutherian mammal you know i would like i
could tell you all these facts that were
kind of meaningless at the time but um
i've always been fascinated by the
inventory of different animals on the
planet and their different behaviors and
so
yeah voracious reader and still now if
you're sitting in a meditation and your
body's thrown the kitchen sink at you
and saying ed you're a loser you're
never going to change this is too hard
why don't you quit and you're aware that
that's your body doing that and you say
to your body
we're going to sit here
and we're going to sit in this fire and
i'm going to keep applying the formula
and my your brain starts running to all
the emails you have to do and you become
aware of that and return back to the
present moment you tell the body it's no
longer the mind that you're the mind now
your will is getting greater than that
program and there's a liberation of
energy and every time you do that that's
a victory
and you teach every time you do that
that's a victory when your mind tells
the body i'm in charge when you say
you're when you you just want to get up
and you want to quit and you go
no that's my body bring it back okay and
now you're now you're taming the animal
the body is the animal and you're like a
dog you sit
and if you keep doing this keep doing
this you're climbing on top and the body
finally acquiesces it finally says i'm
not going anywhere and then boom there's
this liberation of energy what's the
side effect
joy
person's heart just automatically opens
up and and
every time they do that those victories
add up there's no such thing as a bad
meditation there's only overcoming
yourself and when you sit in the fire
and you work with that people say to me
why do you meditate every morning i say
because if i can overcome myself in the
morning the rest of my day is easy it's
easy because because that's what it's
about you master yourself you master
your life yes and so then all the
chatter in your head that you listen to
all day long that is called the default
mode network in the brain my research
shows that shuts off not just shuts off
during the meditation it stays shut off
for the rest of the day so the critic in
your head that's telling you this will
never happen you don't have enough time
all right that there's no voice there so
you just have a clear
flow on where you're going and you trust
yourself more
[Music]
if you want to know the fastest way to
break your bad habits check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there the reason why we go
back to old habits is because our goals
are too lofty
we're not achieving our goals fast
enough i got people think they meet
people like you know they're like
they're robots their other life forms
they're just different than me